that was a scene from the new
documentary by social anthropologist yan
Bella I'm Marta wisdom and you're
watching our day so yang what did you
want to achieve with this film I wanted
to create a film about poverty and
support the reality with EU statistics
this film focuses on a multi-dimensional
measure called the at risk of poverty or
social exclusion indicator it's a
combination of three different measures
income material resources and employment
levels you can imagine these as three
circles in the first circle here poverty
is defined by finding where a person
with a low income stands relative to the
middle income earner in their country in
2010 81 million people had incomes which
were considerably lower than their
fellow countrymen this is a relative
measure because it's based on
comparisons it's country specific and
changes over time for example the at
risk of poverty threshold for
single-person households increase
between 2009 and 20 10 to 19 thousand
four hundred euros in Luxembourg and
decreased to 1222 euros in Romania as
you see here 40 million were living in
severely constrained conditions this
means they were unable to afford four
out of nine items identified on the EU
list these include examples such as the
ability to pay rent and afford a holiday
as the list is a common standard for all
EU countries this makes the measure an
absolute won the third measure is about
employment levels this includes people
who live in households were working age
members worked less than twenty percent
of their full potential this was the
case for 38 million people in 2010 we
then combined the three measures to get
one single number so in total 116
million people that's almost a quarter
of the year you were at risk of poverty
or social exclusion in 2010 the three
circles overlap meaning that a person
may be affected by two and even three
factors
this last situation affects nearly 7.5
million people well the numbers
certainly tell a story in themselves
you've mentioned the term social
exclusion here what do you mean by that
well specifically in the EU poverty and
social exclusion go hand-in-hand with
regard to this indicator social
exclusion primarily means that a person
is economically deprived of living a
full social life but in the EU social
exclusion can mean much more than
economic shortages well I know your film
explains it so let's take a look and see
what the statistics can tell us Maria is
ill and would benefit from special
treatment I've always such as long as I
have food and shelter then I have
everything I need but now I feel if I
wasn't so poor then I'd receive better
treatment like Maria in 2010 about 2% of
the EU believed their medical needs were
not met because they couldn't afford it
when dad lost his job two years we had
to move to a smaller place and I
couldn't have my friends over anymore
because mum said there wasn't enough
room my parents can invite their friends
over
my brother stopped going to school he's
dropped out now and taken a summer job
for Eva's father unemployment has
changed his family's lives dramatically
he is one of the three point nine
percent of EU citizens who were
long-term unemployed in 2010 Eva's
brother is one of the fourteen percent
of young EU citizens in 2010 who dropped
out of school early and didn't continue
with any education or training this has
exposed him to a greater risk of
unemployment and social isolation that
is already happening to his family
according to statistics poor people are
twice as likely to be socially isolated
poverty can easily become a vicious
circle thank you for sharing it with us
young it's certainly a thought-provoking
film statistics help us understand the
different facets of social exclusion and
because of its presence when we talk
about poverty in the EU we're concerned
with issues that go beyond just income
these include lack of access to jobs
education and healthcare with issues
like social isolation we're equally
concerned with the way that damaged
personal relationships can hum the
individual well-being in the film
poverty is described as a vicious circle
is there ever an escape from this yes
there can be and I think statistics play
a crucial role because the right
indicators help us make the right
decisions according to eurostat in the
EU between 2005 and 2010 around 2
million people were lifted out of
poverty and social exclusion every year
by 2020 this number should accumulate to
20 million at least so we're on the
right path towards sustainable
development
you